showtimes new documentary film 100%
Julian Edelman premieres this Friday at
9:00 Eastern and Pacific coasts
streaming on-demand narrated by Michael
Rapaport and you got Mark Wahlberg Snoop
Dogg Tom Brady Michael Strahan Deion
Sanders as we look inside Julian Edelman
is underdog journey from major injury
NFL suspension to Super Bowl MVP Julian
good morning let me start with that
question if you had the opportunity to
be 6-3 or run of for 340 which one would
you take for three yep that's what I
thought what is your best time ever four
four six what do you run now no I ran a
40 in 11 years
I think it's overrated
I think the 40 is over it I would rather
know how fast you can get to top end
speed I'd rather know how quick you are
off the ball in the first 5 to 7 to 10
yards what do you think of that as
opposed to the 40-yard dash I think you
put on filming watch football speed I
think that's more important than timing
or this or that because when you have
someone chasing you
it's a little different so I would
evaluate that more than trying to get a
quantitative number on 40 speedy pace
that and the other
well Jerry Rice had football speed he's
the classic example it was like he ran a
4 640 but it didn't feel like anybody
ever caught him from behind
well without a doubt I mean you know and
you can even put drunk in that category
I mean and you were seeing someone catch
crawled from behind after they farmed
some I mean there's a difference between
football speed and guys that could test
playing fast and and going out and being
fast is different will you miss Gronk
more on the field or off the field I
mean it's hard to say that you're not
going to miss him on the field because
of how dynamic of a player he was and
how big showed up in crucial situations
but I probably say in the locker room um
more just because I you know he was
always always had a good he always he
was always on you know it could be you
know week 11 coming off of a long road
trip into a short week and those
practices are grueling tough you got an
ankle injury you don't feel great
mentally this that in the other you look
in and you see drunk in his locker
probably half naked you're gonna smile
and say we feel good every day and
that's kind of teammate he was and just
you just say just a big big jolly guy
brady ever yell at him and tell him to
get serious um not i'm not really i mean
you didn't have to nothing he's even
yourself motivated guy and he's a very
disciplined guy when it comes to his
work but he just has fun doing it tell
me how this documentary came about well
it came out when it came about by we
originally gonna start shooting
something in 2017 during that playoff
run we played atlanta and you know i got
kind of scared and chickened out didn't
want to mess with my routine you know my
my my business partner i started the
production company coast with a sauce
came up to me he goes well we messed up
on that that could have been cool and
kinda done i yelled at me and then i was
like whatever
next time i'll do it and it just so
happened that uh i tore my ACL and third
preseason week and he came up to me
again and he gave ya that look like a
this would be you know something we
could do and it took me a little time
letting pass and kind of thought about
it and it gave me an opportunity to use
my creative side and then kind of work
out something and occupied my time in my
mind so i wouldn't be going crazy
and that's kind of what we did how much
nudity is in the documentary julie and
that's really what i want to know
nudity there's I don't think there's
that much nudity hmm sex out sex sells
yeah I know like what are you doing if
you want the ladies to watch you got em
come on you got some tighty-whiteys in
there what was the hardest thing to
reveal during this documentary I would
say probably just kind of like the
Family Matters you know going into a
stir and watching and rewatching it kind
of opens up a lot you're telling a lot
about yourself and that stuff was it was
kind of hard to see but hard to watch
for me not hard but like it was just it
was uncomfortable at times just because
I got it got kind of in-depth with you
know a lot of other issues that I was
going through and you know that was
probably the toughest part but when you
when you get suspended are you are you
angry are you embarrassed or like how do
you deal with that with the with a
documentary your career all of them your
everything you you know you thinking of
all that and you're also you have a
regular life you know family you know
and then you have a profession that
you're trying to you know overcome a
major injury yeah you didn't want all
that and you know it was definitely
weird and tough but you know I had some
of my closer friends that you know who
came or guys that's not new and and went
you know I was able to film without
being too uncomfortable also parenting
we talked about when you had your
daughter how important was it to kind of
show that side of you I mean that that
was awesome of looking back on it it is
it's coming something I could always in
a
we had like a family family and and see
some of the interactions though my
daughter with me my family my father my
mother my brother and my sister and
other relatives I mean it's just
something that uh that was probably my
favorite part of it is kind of reliving
that because you know as an athlete you
you don't always get time to appreciate
you know everything that you have in
your life you're so caught up with the
next year and what you got to do this
year to get better and training and
reinventing yourself and adding things
to your game and sometimes to be able to
sit back and watch that and see the
actual story it was kind of refreshing
you know he's Julian Edelman the new
documentary is 100% Julian Edelman it
premieres this Friday on Showtime at
9:00 Eastern and Pacific you watch the
Super Bowls have you gone back to watch
them not not so much um I mean I watch i
watch like the cut-ups the day after day
after we usually player night up just
kind of see certain plays but other than
that you get caught up so many other
things you don't really have time to and
you move on honestly so what's the
better catcher against Seattle or
against Atlanta like more important to
you if you were going to show one play
that you made in your career which one
would you show I would probably say that
third 14 Kesha not even the kitchen
either those two really talk about what
you had talking about the Ricochet and
well no you had the one where you got
blasted by kam chancellor and somehow
you held on to the ball and actually
advanced the ball that's my favorite
catch she ever made because I heard that
hit I was down on the sidelines I went
oh my god that's a car
accident yeah I think it's problem that
was the one I was talking about I know
yeah I mean that was it that was a
pretty cool catch the other one was
little you know there's a little luck
here there and I mean obviously you got
to watch the ball and put yourself in
position to potentially make plays but I
mean a lot of that one kind of was like
a fluke you played I don't know one was
kind of you know wrap up and brace up
for this this collision supposed to
happen and you know you know for in time
in the game so that was pretty cool
catch I guess if you ever got married
would you invite Bill Belichick to the
wedding dependent if he if he knew the
lady that I was going to marry or news
bureau Linda if they had a connection I
don't know on our variables Belichick
the other check strikes me is a good
dancer you know it might be a good guy
to have there at the reception great you
get him and Brady out you know cuz Brady
can't dance it'd be great you get those
guys out there on the dance floor
oh you know that would that would be
that'd be a lifelong memory yeah but
then you have Gronk out there he'll take
his shirt off who knows what happens I
mean well that could be a mess I think
that could be fun that will be the
second part of the documentary that is
that you know after you're done with
football by the way who plays longer you
were Brady I hope I do I hope I do no
guarantees no Brady there's no
guarantees and honestly just focused on
this year and excited for this year and
excited for the process of going out and
you know developing our team and and
learning our team and improving with our
team and working you know it's this is
start of each year these these kind of
phases and they're all important
and I'm looking forward to enjoying that
process by the way you guys want to take
a guess how many tackles Julian Edelman
has in his career
115 game career I'm asking guys on the
other side of the glass here Julia
anybody want to take it out you don't
even know how many tackles you have do I
don't okay all right Paulie
I'll go five five princey I'm gonna say
seven all right Seton twelve McLovin
nine I got you with 25 tackles in your
115 game career is that a defense
special teams and potentially
interception you think so
Tom never throws interceptions though
Julian so I don't I don't know what
you're talking about there Tom never
throws interceptions exactly hey good
luck with the documentary hope to see
you soon get you in studio again and
good luck more importantly with your
daughter in the upcoming season
I appreciate Dana I'm still always
amazed on how great your voice sounds on
radio thank you it's like my voice
sounds like Brady looks good luck with
the documentary Thank You Julian thanks
Julian Edelman Pedro's wide receiver
three-time Super Bowl champ and it's
100% Julian Edelman premieres Friday
9:00 Eastern and Pacific for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]